well millions of people around the world
have had the coronavirus and recovered
we also know that millions more have
probably had the virus
and not even known it but does exposure
to covet 19 does it make us
immune there's now mounting evidence
that being infected with the coronavirus
does not prevent a re-infection in hong
kong a 33-year-old man contracted the
virus in april and recovered
when he returned from a trip to spain in
august he tested positive
again doctors say it's the first
documented case of re-infection
some people ask if they'll be immune to
the virus forever after they recover
there wasn't a clear answer before but
now it's very clear
after your first infection there'll
always be a chance you'll get infected
again
scientists today reported two more cases
of patients in the netherlands in
belgium
catching covet 19 a second time but the
world health organization is urging calm
here
saying reinfections are not likely to
happen
too often the important other important
thing to note
is the numbers are very very small so
this is one documented case
in over 23 million and we will probably
see other documented cases but it seems
to be
uh not a regular event we would have
seen many more cases
well my next guest tonight is a familiar
face to our viewers he's a trusted voice
in all questions concerning the
coronavirus pandemic dr
john campbell joins me tonight from
carlisle england dr campbell it's good
to see you again
um how worried should we be
about reinfection i mean i was thinking
today we catch the common cold
through a virus many times in our lives
we do but the common cold virus changes
very quickly and there's various forms
of it
and there's a rapid mutation rate in
that particular form of virus
now what these studies have done is
they've unequivocally proved that
someone have coronavirus
infection with covid19 and get it a
second time
and we have conclusive proof that this
has happened three times
out of 23 to 24 million cases
so i really think we have to keep this
in perspective
now this isn't really um this isn't
really surprising we've had anecdotal
cases of people being reinfected before
but the difference is these first three
cases that we have the one in hong kong
as you say the one in the netherlands
and the one in belgium
these have been officially confirmed by
phylogenetic analysis the scientists
have looked at the genetics of the virus
and they've known that the virus the
person was infected the first time
is a different genetic strain to the
virus they've been infected with the
second time
so we know that this happens but we have
to bear in mind that we also know that
coronavirus does induce
an immunological reaction we know it
induces
surface acting antibodies we know it
induces in most people
the immunoglobulin antibodies in the
blood and perhaps most importantly
of all we also know it induces a t cell
response which is much more likely to be
long lived
so i think it's very much a time to keep
this in perspective
we are talking about three cases now i
do expect there to be more documented
cases
but we have to bear in mind we've had a
high index of suspicion of this for some
time now we've been looking out for this
and a lot of people have been tested and
retested and yet these are only the
first three definitive cases that have
been confirmed by the microbiologists
and virologists dr campbell what does
this reinfection what does it mean if
anything for the
efficacy of a vaccine
well if people were to be reinfected
regularly then
that means they would not have a
sustained immunological response
so they could catch the virus the immune
system would
basically forget how to recognize that
virus and then they would recatch it
and of course all a vaccine does is is
imitate the natural infection
so if people were to get reinfected
because the immunity faded
then people could be vaccinated and then
within a few months or
who knows how long three four months or
six months or so
then they could be reinfected again if
the immune response was not
long lived but at the moment i think the
evidence suggesting that the immune
response is long-lived
is much more than these individual cases
because we don't know the full details
of these cases
yet the hong kong case for example is
all rather strange
it's only circulating on social media at
the moment it's not a peer-reviewed
paper as yet
i expect it to be but it's just strange
that it hasn't even been formally
released in pre-print and yet the
world's press is talking about this
but you can understand this because the
implications are very significant
and if immunity was to fade then that
means herd immunity wouldn't be
able to be generated as well and we
could be stuck with this virus
reinfecting people for a long long time
but i think the balance of evidence at
the moment is saying that there will be
immunity
and we're already seeing some of the
epidemiological benefits of herd
immunity
in some parts of the world such as new
york where a level of herd immunity
combined with the control measures the
hand washing the distancing the mask
wearing
are combining to reduce the amount of
infections that we're seeing
dr kim i've got about 30 seconds let me
ask you could the vaccine
for coronavirus be like the flu vaccine
the flu shot that we have to get it
every year
i got about 30 seconds yeah i suspect
not because there's many different sorts
of flu viruses but there's only one sort
of coronavis coronavirus covered 19.
so i strongly suspect that is not the
case i remain optimistic about the
vaccine
all right always optimistic dr john
campbell it's always good speaking with
you dr campbell thank you
thank you
you